the Pentagon working to recover debris
and solve unanswered questions after a
U.S fighter jet shot down a flying
object for the second time in a week
President Biden ordered the military to
take down the unidentified object
hovering over the remote and Frozen
northern coast of Alaska on Friday the
White House says the object posed a
reasonable threat to the safety of
Civilian flights but the device's origin
remains unknown this morning the twin
downings have led to heightened concerns
over China's vast surveillance program
and lawmakers are still pressing the
Biden Administration for answers on the
military's response Christina raffini is
at the White House with the very latest
Christina good morning
good morning Michelle the White House
says President Biden ordered this latest
shoot down on the advice of the Pentagon
and out of an abundance of caution but
they're still not sure exactly what this
object was and if it posed a threat
we're calling this an object because
that's the best description we have
right now the unidentified floating
object roughly the size of a small car
was shot down by fighter jets over the
icy waters of Alaska the White House
says whatever it was was flying at a
height of about forty thousand feet over
the state's northern coast and posed a
reasonable threat to the safety of
Civilian flight and it came in inside
our territorial Waters those Waters
right now are frozen but inside
territorial airspace and over territory
Waters
a recovery effort is now underway to
retrieve the wreckage but it comes less
than a week after the military shot down
a massive Chinese spy balloon that
floated over several States for seven
days before the military shot it down
over the Waters of South Carolina what
is concerning
um is that it was yet another
unidentified object
violating
U.S sovereignty Alaska's senior senator
Republican Lisa murkowski any aspect of
U.S Sovereign territory that
is is encroached upon there's going to
be consequences to it Alaska's Junior
Senator Republican Dan Sullivan says the
latest incidents highlight the need for
the U.S to invest in better detection
systems whether the threat is a
slow-moving balloon or an
intercontinental ballistic missile our
um Homeland defense needs an upgrade in
all those areas and I think this is a
wake-up call but former Secretary of
Defense Mark esper told CBS the quick
action might be evidence the U.S has
already taken some of those steps maybe
today's
demonstration of uh closing the Gap and
shooting down this unidentified object
is evidence of that but there's clearly
work needs to be done in terms of
addressing the Aerospace picture that we
see still he said it's too soon to know
if this latest object really posed a
threat this may end up being some type
of weather balloon or scientific
experiment or or climate research who
knows but I think we need to withhold
some judgment first
and yesterday the treasury Department
announced export controls on six Chinese
companies they say are involved in
manufacturing or manufacturing the parts
for these type of surveillance balloons
and the U.S says these balloons have
been floated over 40 countries around
the world guys
all right Christina thank you